[Music]
have you ever wondered what Beast Boy
would look like as beast girl or cyborg
as she Borg you're gonna find out we are
featuring fantastic work of some of the
most talented team Titans go fans don't
forget to subscribe to the things and
give this video a big thumbs up now
let's check out 10 Teen Titans go
characters reimagined as opposite
genders beast girl let's start with one
of the most hardcore but probably the
most realistic character of them all
Beast Boy looks pretty cute but check
out this awesome version of this girl
this photo was illustrated by showman's
from deviantART and it looks absolutely
amazing this is as realistic as it goes
so not only is Beast Boy now a girl he's
also done in an incredibly realistic way
this girl looks pretty good and we just
can't get over the detail on this design
this artist totally nailed the look the
character and the entire attitude to she
Borg okay you know we have to mention
cyborg who's by far one of the best
characters on this show he's absolutely
hilarious but incredibly level-headed
when it comes to trying to tame his
hyper friends meet she Borg a character
designed by Cookie Monster from
deviantART isn't this just the most
amazing thing ever although this she
Borg is already an adult it's one of the
best illustrations ever and we just had
to share it
check out her pretty impressive detail
and the awesome looking hair having a
she Borg instead of a cyborg would
actually make Teen Titans go much more
interesting Raven
it's no secret Raven is our second fav
who doesn't love Raven she's incredibly
sarcastic but she can still always make
us laugh even if her humor seems to be
quite negative and here she is
reimagined by Homestuck 11:23 from
deviantART or should we say here he is
come to think of it if you add the hood
to this character he wouldn't look any
different than Raven does but either way
you have to admit that Raven is pretty
cool and purple looks extremely good on
both characters the gang's all here
the talented teen titans go fans really
love to reimagine the characters as the
opposite gender we can't blame them
because these photos definitely look
like these characters would be a lot of
fun before we move on to Starfire and
some of the other characters check out
all of them together
this photo belongs to Claudia Pascua
from deviantART and it's absolutely
marvelous we bet there wouldn't even be
any difference if the Teen Titans go
characters change their gender the best
thing about this picture is that Raven
pretty much still looks the same
Robin of course we also have to talk
about the one and only Robin he might be
pretty controlling and manipulative but
we still can't help but love him he's a
perfectionist after all so let's not
hold that against him
Corinth from deviantART beautifully
reimagined what Robin would look like as
a female we're telling you we'd totally
watch all these characters in action
Robin looks like she could definitely
kick some butt jinx let's not forget
about the pink haired jinx jinx is
probably one of the most awesome Teen
Titans go characters and she definitely
isn't given enough credit we do love her
but we also love this reimagined version
of her as a male check it out
this illustration belongs to beast green
from deviantART and it's amazing the
male jinx doesn't have another name but
why should he anyway
this definitely suits him and we're
still loving the pink hair the boys so
let's have a look at all the boys or
should we say all the girls
this illustration belongs to deviantART
user Glee Chan and they look pretty
awesome so instead of cyborg Robin and
Beast Boy
we have female versions of their
characters we can't decide which one
looks better because they're all pretty
awesome Teen Titans go really needs to
create the storyline with gender bent
characters because we'd all be watching
these illustrations can definitely serve
as inspiration we just can't get over
how adorable cyborg looks on this one
the lovebirds ah it's everyone's
favorite ship who doesn't love Beast Boy
and Raven together they are so adorable
but what's even better is this gender
swap version of the two lovebirds the
photo belongs to kasumi-chan from
deviantART and it's fantastic we are
totes diggin the Beast girl with her
long green hair and of course Raven
looks as studious as ever and he looks
like he has no idea what to do while
beasts girl is totally smitten seriously
we really need this to happen because
it's absolutely adorable we are for sure
on board with this glorious ship the
girls we couldn't get all the girls in
there but Starfire and Raven are pretty
EPIK this illustration was created by
bunny with snake from deviantART and it
really is the most amazing thing ever
we're telling you purple looks really
good on Raven no matter what and
Starfire's version is exactly what we'd
imagine is a male Starfire to look like
the short hair is looking really cool we
love that the artist kept their
attitudes Starfire is playful while
Raven is his usual grumpy self even in
male form
seems like nothing has really changed
all of them and here they are
the entire crew once again we just can't
get over how good this team looks even
when they change genders they really
should do a gender swap episode not only
would it be absolutely hilarious we bet
it would be one of the best episodes
ever especially if the characters look
like this this photo was uploaded by
lady legasus on wikia don't they look
awesome we're not letting them wrap the
next season without introducing these
characters as a part of the story come
on Teen Titans go let's make it happen
and that's it for our video thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]